yeah when you think of a record like the
box
that's a song that um
i think of like how you know there's a
lot of records like jay-z and kanye's in
paris roddy rich is the box like where
you would be in the club
you can play that [ __ ] for 15 minutes
straight
back to back to back
there's probably like three or four of
those in the last like 15 years yeah and
that's one of them
that's hard like it's crazy to like
think i appreciate that that's crazy
that's hard bro i mean [ __ ] i'm sure
you've been in the club where they
brought that [ __ ] i mean that no i mean
yeah but when you yeah i mean [ __ ] yeah
that's that's that's hard though [ __ ]
diamond record man yeah yeah you've
gotten to the point of famous
where you can't even go to a basketball
game without people assuming that you're
dating that person like
at what point was there a specific
moment
where you realized [ __ ] was just
different like
like [ __ ] really is different now like
you can't move the way you maybe used to
move was there like a specific moment
where you just kind of realized like
[ __ ] like i don't be tripping like at
the end of the day
i just move
how i want to and i feel like in that
evening i'm i'm able to
still
be discreet and do my own thug like
um you know i just feel like [ __ ] the
world is gonna think whatever they want
to but at the end of the day i just i
move cool i don't bother nobody don't
nobody bother me if you mean i [ __ ] with
who i [ __ ] with you know it's just that
that's how i be really that's fair man
um i know you're sitting on a bunch of
music
i'm curious
how many different times because over a
two-year period we went obviously
you had your first tour which
was crazy because you were you were
performing in venues that um
were big but but for as big as the album
was
you know
the tour was already booked so you were
selling out like
2 000 seat cedars you know what i'm
saying but i don't feel like you really
had the moment
that
you deserve to have touring wise because
the pandemic hit
um
how did you deal with like
kind of having to sit down
i know you lost out on a lot of festival
money because that summer was going to
be crazy for you like
did you just
like how did you redirect all that
energy like in the middle of the
pandemic that [ __ ] was kind of crazy the
first like six or seven months man yeah
i felt like it's all in god's timing and
you know i feel like um just
who i am i just always accept
that you feel me what god has for me is
for me and what is not is not and you
know a lot of people will be frustrated
or flustered by that but
i honestly didn't miss out on any sleep
i actually got a good chance to be
around um my family and you know
be able to
get stronger relationships with people
that you know actually
care about a [ __ ] so
that's more important than using me uh
being on the stage or doing anything and
i love my fans and i've had the luxury
of being able to end the pandemic and
i'm still doing what i love and i still
i'm still doing what i do so that's just
in itself that's like a blessing
for me i always look at the positives i
don't try to look at it like it was a
bad thing necessarily because i might
not have been ready for it
and you feel me you know that's that's
what that could have been so i could
have been ready for it i couldn't but
god knew so he just made my path how he
make it yeah i feel like a lot of people
instead of focusing on the positive of
any situation that was let the negative
take them out bro like you got to look
at the positive in every situation yeah
bro because at the end of the day
if you got a negative mindset you're
going to attract that energy to you and
that's never good for nobody yeah
like i always tell my young homies is
just like [ __ ]
it's just about
what you can give to the world it ain't
about what the world could give to you
and that's game from
nipsey you feel me it's like more so
you gotta give your all to this [ __ ] the
game don't really owe you nothing nobody
owes you anything you feel me just just
as much as
i could be doing it i could not be doing
it so i just take my blessings with with
a smile you feel me where do you keep
the grammy for racks in the middle at
the crib where's it at my office
that's a that's a
man it's a big
big award
and that specific award just meant so
much i feel like to so many people you
know what i'm saying
like uh shout out to hip boy did you get
in with hit boy at all in terms of like
just recently like i feel like
that record is so iconic i feel like
it'd only be right whatever project
that's coming you guys gets get one on i
feel like we gotta we got a lot of
joints but you feel me it's just about
time in it just figuring out what fits
you feel me like i'm honestly the
wreck's in the middle [ __ ] i had did
that after i did like six songs with
with pluto i did that song and my voice
was wasn't
it wasn't um i could i was hoarse you
didn't take songs of the future yeah
that night and then when i ended up
doing that one last one because i had to
get in with it and could we be just
going in after that initial first song
that was the first song i did with him
boy and then we kept doing music and so
that's why i said it's like timing
because with that song if nifty wouldn't
have picked it you know i probably would
have just been like all right that's
another one we've gotten yeah we had to
figure it out later and
i mean honestly you know it's just about
timing with this [ __ ] like it ain't it
ain't no
like with me and mustard it ain't really
no pressure like we don't be like oh we
gonna drop on these [ __ ] or we gonna
sell this many records like we've sold
down there 20 million records together
and never
been like [ __ ] we have to sell these
records it just happened just happens
organically yeah you only like over
overthinking it that's what happens
people overthink [ __ ] yo you you we just
can't pass over you at six songs with
future in one night
yeah
this kind of [ __ ] happens a lot where
you hear like artists like yo i got 25
songs with kanye or some [ __ ] it's like
yo where do these songs end like where
are they at like are we ever gonna hear
him i mean
i'm just i'm the type of guy bro i just
work a lot
like i work a lot on my way to my radio
station
interviews and stuff i'm on the calls
with you for me the touring people and i
just i just be working a lot workaholic
i'm sure i'm sure the live show is going
to be crazy on this definitely